which religion has the most kids okay
and the change in global religious
landscape babies born and Muslims will
begin to outnumber Christian births by
2035 okay and people with no religion
face a birth dearth okay great name so
uh babies born to Muslims so show the
data there show the data go a little bit
lower so we can see that there you go so
Christians read Muslims green Christians
are not having babies like they once
were having and Muslims are having more
babies so if this is from Pure research
and you got to trust pure research they
don't they're not on one side or the
other they're just going to give you the
data that they have they're they don't
it's facts it's not CNN or Fox so go a
little lower to see if there's any more
data to look at here uh go a little
lower to see if we have anybody else
okay there you go so let's look at this
one here estimated shares of birth and
deaths compared to what their shared
number of overall 2015 population
Christians make up the largest share of
2010 that's Muslims a largest share of
birds okay if you look at that number 31
to 21 but Christians there's more dying
than being born Muslims that have 10
percent more being born than dying and
then if you look at the disparity by 25
and 26 26 2055 and 2060. okay Muslim
religion is going to get bigger than
Christians in the world because Muslims
are having more kids if I'm a Christian
leader at the top and I'm a leader of a
thousand churches I'm probably having
this conversation with my community by
the way shout out to Mormons for having
more kids yeah they're growing their
base more I know this this could be kind
of funny like we're being funny about it
I'm actually not yeah I think if you
really want to your competition is
having more kids than you are okay and
there's going to be more population
there to impose their way of thinking of
course and believe in and they're gonna
outnumber you yeah okay so Christians
hey go make some babies today because
that number is not looking good for you
then go to the next one that I sent to
you which was what causes population to
increase by the way this entire time
while you guys are talking I mean I've
been looking at this stuff actually
really curious to know what the hell is
going on here with this I'd like to
revisit that optimism we'll come back to
it so go and just Google the following
just Google in another page Google
largest population of religion you just
put largest religion population so all
the way at the top Christianity right
now is what first place 2.382 it ain't
gonna be there for too long no it's not
Muslims are 1.907 which is 25 and then
you have the rest secular and then you
have Hindus and 1.161 hit more Rose rub
you trying to see Jews I'm just trying
to see my people where we're at yeah
give them some recognition I don't know
his competition yet
to wipe us out zoom in 14.7 million I
don't know if you guys realize what pat
pat you made a really good point once
that shift starts happening it's the and
people don't think about it I'm not
saying good or bad thing but this is
this is a Christian country by a big
percentage the the policies
Judea Christian but think about this all
the all the people all the decisions all
the all the Mayors all the everything
but it's going to be a complete shift on
the religion that runs and you're gonna
see change you know you know it's crazy
you know it's crazy the average person's
watching this right now the average
listener listening to this right now
they're like who cares about this yeah
yeah you don't care about it you're 42
years old yeah you got your job you're
laughing maybe it's like ah it's not a
big deal oh 40 years from now you will
see how different things will look when
you look at Congress 30 of Congress are
going to be Muslims and you know 30 of
senators and then all of a sudden U.S is
a Muslim uh president and then hey
what's wrong with that nothing's wrong
with that and now you know the the
the and this isn't to fear that this
isn't to fear that this is if you have a
certain belief and you have a lot of
pride in that well then show up and make
some babies and raise some leaders and
inject your philosophy into this because
Muslims get a shout out for absolutely
doing that better than Christians are
doing it right now the the stat that you
just showed was that for the world or
the United world population okay so so I
don't think that has a uh direct effect
on on the United States in the sense
that well in a sense that
our Muslim population would have to
would have to grow at an even faster
rate than that because most of our
immigrants are actually coming to the
country but from other Christians
Nations such as Catholics from from
Latin America
say that one more time well most of the
immigration into the United States most
of the population growth is happening in
within the within the Hispanic Community
they've grown which is 24 yeah yes 24
but uh when when you when you have a
long-term thinking mindset and your
opponent does not it's just a matter of
time until you infiltrate universities
until you infiltrate educational system
until you infiltrate school systems
until you infiltrate build in churches
until you infiltrate politics until you
infiltrate media until you they're
already doing it right now anyways and
by the way this isn't a if you're if
you're Muslim and you're a leader of
Islam your kudos to you strategically
Christians are sitting on the sidelines
being very casual about it and it's
almost like the competitor that thinks
ah it's not a big deal you know they're
never going to pass us up okay brace for
impact because it's going to come very
very quickly and when it hits you the
difference between Muslims and
Christians is what the other day this
Dar what's his name the football player
who wore that jacket and uh uh wore that
jacket at Super Bowl did you see the
jacket he wore mocking Jesus yeah yeah
dude
the guy that almost died on the field
yeah and he was praying what yeah and
the AOC said something he wears this
jacket mocking Jesus and you know what
is that yeah so he wears this jacket
after he was praising Jesus you know who
called him out Adrian Peterson pulls him
out and tweets about and says what kind
of a thing are you wearing and then some
you know there's stuff in football right
now saying you should tell them that
privately you shouldn't tell them that
publicly Peterson's like what are you
doing what is the guy that almost lost
his life the guy that was like oh you
should be freaking the guy that the
first thing was Lord gloves me and the
God was looking at me and then he did
that so but here's a point though here's
the point somebody here's what they're
going to say though someone's gonna say
oh grow up guys this is called Art yeah
this is called Art really no problem why
don't you do the same art in Prophet
Muhammad and let's see if you'll call
that art as well I'm wearing the Super
Bowl go ahead and do that but here's a
point here's the point the point is
Christians tend to be forgiven and they
say let it slide Muslims are not no they
don't play games and say let it slide so
there is that standard and expectation
where if somebody sits let's just say
you have two kids one kid you joke with
he takes it the other kid you joke with
he says don't do that again that I don't
like that when you do that in front of
people okay guess whose standard you're
going to step up to as a parent the kid
that tells you don't make fun of me in
front of my friends that's exactly
what's happening here one religion's
like ah it's okay let it slide the other
religion's like no don't do it so not
only are they growing faster they're
more disciplined they believe more they
have higher standard and expectations of
their members there is a more
disciplined way of what you need to do
on a daily basis praying the the level
of commitment to that religion is much
higher 100 so that's what they're
injecting and they're gonna figure out a
way to get into different communities if
you believe the future looks bright
order your future looks bright hat today
foreign
[Music]